here are two actors who are reading
raves over there co-starring film The
Silence of the Lambs ooh great movie
thank you in which him which he plays an
FBI agent and he plays a serial killer
known as Hannibal the cannibal I know
she won an Oscar his Best Actress for
the accused and he's backstage having a
snack and we've just lost John Goodman
ladies and gentlemen here Anthony
Hopkins and Jodie Foster
the late screenwriter Dorothy Parker
once said that the two most beautiful
words in the English language are check
and closed what mr. Parker might have
added from her personal experience is
that the two most challenging words to a
screenwriter are fade in five writers
who successfully met that challenge have
been nominated for Best Screenplay
written directly for the screen their
names are Woody Allen for Alice
Barry Levinson for Avalon
Chris Joel Rubin for gust
Peter Weir for green card
whit stillman for metropolitan and the
Oscar for screenplay written directly to
the screen goes to Wow who is it Johnny
and the Oscar goes to Bruce ja rhumann
forgot
well thank you very much I have to tell
you I'm just honored to be associated
with a film that not only acknowledges
the spiritual nature of man but affirms
it thank you
to Jerry Zucker our director whose
beautiful heart is on every frame of
this film to our producers Lisa
Weinstein the Howard W Koch and Steven
Charles Jaffe thank you to the everyone
at Paramount all the executives past and
present who were involved in this film
and who believed in it especially
Lindsay Duran thank you to the cast and
crew particularly Whoopi Goldberg who
deserves every award that she won thank
you to my parents Jim and Sandra my sons
Josh and Ari and my wife Blanche who six
years ago put our house on the market
quit her job and said we're moving to
Hollywood thanks hon and thank you Rudy